we've got three questions three answers
before we have a look at the answers I
want us to all look at the first one
together and regardless of whether the
value at the bottom is right on and here
this is a quick easy way all of us can
very simply improve this solution not
add anything to it is actually something
I reckon we could take away that would
make it a little bit clearer yeah so
there's a lot of equal signs there we
need some of it because it is an
equation after all but we've a few extra
ones which ones would you like me to
maybe remove it just these ones over
here right now I get one in there I
think often the first time you start
doing math problems you're like well
it's kind of like a substitute for the
next step like an error like okay my
next step in logic my next step in logic
and to be fair you know we kind of
trained you to do that because this
machine B it works by every time you
want to go to the next step you hit back
button right but when we write it we
really want to be clear that equals
means okay these two things on either
side of this are the same and is nothing
okay so I'm just gonna get rid of those
when you have a look at that what do you
think are you happy with it yeah yeah
can you see the way the second ones are
greeting you've got the plus seven which
gets rid of the 17 makes it 12 over
there what was the next thing that
happened what's this about division
because because okay we're trying to get
that X by himself and he's being
multiplied by three
how can we check the x equals fours the
answer chef we can throw it back into
the very first line three times four
three times four is 12 take away seven
is five cool yay
I can maths it is late afternoon um what
do you think of these guys have we got
some agreement yeah thumbs up yeah okay
wonderful now what I want you to do if
you've got another color there is I want
you to circle all the answers you've got
this this and this and this with another
color and I want you to remember that if
what we've asked you to do is solve
these questions then these three things
I've circled in five they are called the
solutions right so I want to label them
as when you solve what you get is the
solution okay now in underneath is
hitting simultaneous equations we're
going to look at similar kinds of
equations but they're very weird because
these solutions are a bit well their
usual for a reason I'll show you why in
a second
okay so here's an example now what I'm
doing is just to make sure we're all on
the same page because just when I had a
look around some of you have now this
idea others you kind of know what
process you're going through you don't
know why it works and then a few others
reviewers took a few so that's fine if I
gave you an equation like this and I
asked you to solve it what would you do
I gave you done
okay so for example I don't write this
down but if you wanted to take a similar
approach to what you did over here you
maybe would say on a cable I'll subtract
1 from both sides just gives you that
and then what might you do okay so I
need something in place of one of the
letters right just watch what happens if
I look at this these little X's right so
what X is we have a name not just solve
it but when you've got X on the left
hand side of the equation what's that
cold you didn't exercise on this last
week
it's clone changing the subject very
good so X is now the subject on all
these equations I can make X 2 subject
to as well I've got to do one more thing
/ - I might as well swap places as well
so they'll give me X over here and y -1
do you agree with that yeah so I changed
the subject but I am no closer to a
solution because like my X's and Y's are
still there I don't even have value for
each of those so it's like what do I do
so what you needs to pick a value okay
in fact you can pick a whole bunch of
different values and this is what you
draw a table for remember this can you
get do you memory trace if you have it
in fact just over here just draw this
particular table for me I know you've
got one of your own ones
yeah now we draw this table because in
our three review questions for each of
them
there was one solution and one solution
alone write x equals 4 and 1/2 there's
nothing else you can put in here that
will make the whole thing work
x equals 2 only option x equals 4 the
only option when you come to this guy
what's the difference between this
equation and saying this one there's
something additional that appears is
another litttle what's this other guy
directly on them there's a y and it's an
X so depending on what Y is or what X is
you can get lots and lots of different
solutions there's not just one in fact
it's an infinite set of them ok so I'm
gonna write some of them down for
example if I said extra equal to
negative 1 right I'm just gonna start
from negative 1 I'm just gonna go add 1
and get lots of lots of different values
if I put in negative 1 into here you can
substitute into this equation right 2
times negative 1 is negative 2 and then
you add 1 which leaves you with hold on
y equals 2 times 1 plus 1 that's
negative 2 plus 1 that's negative 1 or
vibro convinced it's it's fine so now
have a look at this right you know how I
said to you before this is a solution
position this is solution right
this pair of numbers this is one of the
solutions and it's just one of them I
can think of more I just have to pick
different values let's try another one
if I grab x equals zero let's substitute
it in again what are you gonna get 2
times 0 which is 0 you add 1
ok we got the first time this guy okay
good
right and I can keep doing this in fact
I know if I just go up by one every
single time you can crunch the numbers
you should find they go up by two every
time you go ahead you can test it out
okay
so stay with me the first Yoda point out
is okay look I've got heaps of solutions
and these five like he's a solution he's
a solution every pair is a solution on
these five on it there's lots of
solutions I could keep going this way
negative two negative three negative
four I can keep counting that way four
five six seven eight
this even solutions between the
solutions right like I could have stuck
in x equals 1/2 what's 2 times 1/2 it's
1 and plus 1 gives you 2 so 1/2 and 2
it's a nice so I can keep on doing this
forever but what's our take these
equations does is it says okay what if
you've got more than just one of these
guys what if you got say two of them so
he's the we've already
okay now when you were drawing your
tables before you would notice you'd
have to get a pair of them like a pair
tables
now if I again go for this set the
values here write negative 1 0 1 2 & 3
that's just prison by coincidence if I
put in x equals negative 1
have a look this is where I am down
right what are you going to get out of
this so if I just substituted in first 5
not to be sticking your negative 1 what
would you like me to do to both sides
nails I should add 1 to both sides right
which gives me 5
so color negative 1 for the X and 5 is a
solution this one okay
what about if I put in X equal 0 this is
just 4 and in fact it's just gonna count
down like this if you want to go ahead
and test all that now look this is where
the Young Money truck comes in right you
can see that there's an infinite set of
solutions for this guy and as infants
have solutions for this guy right
but there's one solution that'll solve
both of these problems at the same time
it's a bit - you know you're trying to
pick a bunch of me else you're like I
have all my favorite foods that when I
get a food court and have it happen and
then you have all your favorite fruits
that you all have you have a food court
and there might be only one that makes
both of us happy right in other words
makes us happy simultaneously
so you can see there's a solution that's
in common between them and that's all
this means right big scary phrase but
you just want to find a solution that
works for both of them right
simultaneous equations are the
democratic election system in the
mathematics world I want an option
that's happy for not just one way but
for modern one for lots and lots of them
usually in our cases there - well let me
put it this way okay if there are seven
people and you go to the food court and
you want to agree on what you wanna buy
what do you think of the chances that
all seven of you will be able to find a
single food that all of you are happy
eating what do you think it is a good
chance that's all
lousy chance it doesn't depend this
isn't a bad place it depends on the
surface well actually that's exactly the
right answer because I come up with
seven that all agree with each other one
spot but the more you get the harder it
is to have ones that agree okay and
there's a nice visual reason why we
don't get to ladies